imagine looking different from almost
everybody else and then imagine being
teased insulted and bullied for it how
would that make you feel when I was a
boy I was called ginger Ginga and even
Duracell in reference to a batteries
rusty top there's not an awful lot you
can do about having red hair as a child
it's part of our inevitable genetic
makeup and therefore being attacked for
it feels a little bit like being
rejected for who we are at University I
dyed mine peroxide and then for years as
a TV presenter I even shaved my head
it's only been recently that I've had
the confidence to reveal my red roots
and now I feel empowered as an outed
ginger man there does seem to have been
a shift in attitude towards the ginger
gene there's even been speculation that
damian lewis could one day become the
first ginger bond and that really would
be fantastic news for all us redheaded
men because we probably had it a little
bit tougher than ginger women but
whether or not you find us redheads
attractive the nastiness has absolutely
got to stop because bullying and that
after all is what we're talking about
here is not cool it's not clever
it's just cowardly
you